We are now ready to
move on to a model which
is quite interesting
and quite realistic.
This is a model in which we have
an unknown parameter modeled
as a random variable
that we try to estimate.
This is the random
variable, Theta.
And we have multiple
observations
of that random variable.
Each one of those
observations is
equal to the unknown
random variable,
plus some additive noise.
This is a model that appears
quite often in practice.
It is often the case
that we're trying
to estimate a certain
quantity, but we can only
observe values of that quantity
in the presence of noise.
And because of the
noise, what we want to do
is to try to measure
it to multiple times.
And so we have multiple
such measurement equations.
And then we want to combine all
of the observations together
to come up with a good
estimate of that parameter.
The assumption that
we will be making
are that Theta is a
normal random variable.
It has a certain mean
that we denote by x0.
The reason for this strange
notation will be seen later.
And it also has a
certain variance.
The noise terms are also
normal random variables
with 0 mean and a
certain variance.
And finally, we assume that
these basic random variables
that define our model
are all independent.
Based on these assumptions, now
we would like to estimate Theta
on the basis of the X's.
And as usual, in the
Bayesian setting,
what we want to do is to
calculate the posterior
distribution of
Theta, given the X's.
The Bayes rule
has the usual form
for the case of continuous
random variables.
The only remark that needs to
be made is that in this case,
there are multiple X's,
so X up here stands
for the vector of
the observations
that we have obtained.
And similarly,
little x will stand
for the vector of the values
of these observations.
So we need now to start
making some progress
towards calculating
this term here.
What is the distribution of
the vector of measurements
given theta.
Before we move to
the vector case,
let us look at one of the
measurements in isolation.
This is something that
we have already seen.
If I tell you the value
of the random variable,
Theta, which is what happens
in this conditional universe
when you condition on
the value of Theta,
then in that universe,
the random variable, Xi,
is equal to the numerical
value that you gave me
for Theta, plus Wi.
And because Wi is independent
from the random variable Theta,
knowing the value of
the random variable
Theta does not change
the distribution of Wi.
It will still have this
normal distribution.
So Xi is a normal of this
kind plus a constant.
And so Xi is a normal
random variable
with mean equal to the
constant that we added,
and variance equal to
the original variance
of the random variable, Wi.
And so we can now write down,
the PDF, the conditional PDF,
of Xi.
There's going to be a
normalizing constant.
And then the usual
exponential term,
which is going to be xi minus
the mean of the distribution,
which is theta.
And then we divide by
the usual variance term.
Let us move next to
this distribution here.
This is a shorthand
notation for the joint PDF
of the random
variables X1 up to Xn,
conditional on the
random variable Theta.
So it's really a function
of multiple variables.
And how do we proceed now?
Here is the crucial observation.
If I tell you the value of
the random variable capital
Theta as before, then
you argue as follows.
All of these random
variables are independent.
So if I tell you the value
of the random variable Theta,
this does not change the joint
distribution of the Wi's.
The Wi's were independent
when we started,
so they remain independent
in the conditional universe.
And since the Wi's
are independent
and Xi's are obtained from the
Wi's by just adding a constant,
this means that
the Xi's are also
independent in this
conditional universe.
Once I tell you
the value of Theta,
then because the
noises are independent,
the observations are
also independent.
But this means that the joint
PDF factors as a product
of the individual
marginal PDFs of the Xi's.
And these PDFs, we
have already found.
So now, we can put
everything together
to write down a formula
for the posterior PDF
using the Bayes rule.
We have this denominator term,
which I will write first,
and which term we do
not need to evaluate.
Then we have the
marginal PDF of Theta.
Now since Theta is normal
with these parameters,
this is of the form e to
the minus theta minus x0
squared over 2 sigma 0 squared.
And then we have this joint
density of the X's conditioned
on Theta, which we have already
found, it is this product here.
It's a product of n terms,
one for each observation.
And each one of these terms
is what we have found earlier,
so I'm just substituting
this expression up here.
Now once we have obtained the
observations, so the value
of the random variable capital
X, that is, the value little x,
is fixed.
Once it is fixed, then the x's
that appear here are constant.
So in particular, this
term here is a constant.
We do not bother with it.
And what we have is a constant
times an exponential in terms
that are quadratic in theta.
So we recognize this
kind of expression.
It has to correspond to
a normal distribution.
And this is the first
conclusion of this exercise.
That is, the posterior PDF
of the parameter, Theta,
given our observations, this
posterior PDF is normal.
We have e to a quadratic
function in theta.
And that quadratic
function also involves
the specific values of the
X's that we have obtained.
Let us copy what we have
found and rearrange it.
Once more, we have a
constant, then the exponential
of the negative of some
quadratic function in theta.
And the specific
quadratic function
that we calculated just before
takes this particular form.
What is the mean of this
normal distribution?
The mean is same as the peak.
And to find the peak, the
location at which this PDF is
largest, what we do
is we try to find
the place at which this
quadratic function is smallest.
So what we do is to take
the derivative with respect
to theta of this
quadratic, and set it to 0.
This gives us a sum of terms.
The derivative of
the typical term
is going to be theta minus xi,
divided by sigma i squared.
And this expression
must be equal to 0
if theta is at the peak of
the posterior distribution.
And so we now rearrange
this equation.
We split and take first
the term involving theta,
and gives us a
contribution of this kind.
And we move the terms involving
x's to the other side.
And this gives us
this expression.
And finally, we
take this sum here
and send it to the
denominator of the other side.
And this gives us the
final form of the solution:
the peak of the posterior
distribution, which is also
the same as the conditional
expectation of the posterior
distribution.
Whenever we have a
normal distribution,
the expected value is
the same as the place
where the distribution
is largest.
Let us now conclude with a few
comments and words about how
to interpret the
result that we found.
First, let me emphasize that the
same conclusions that we have
obtained for the case
of a single observation
go through in this case as well.
The posterior distribution
of the unknown parameter
is still a normal distribution.
Our state of
knowledge about Theta
after we obtain
the observations is
described by a
normal distribution.
Because it is a
normal distribution,
the location of its peak is
the same as the expected value.
And for this reason, the
conditional expectation
estimate and the maximum
a posteriori probability
estimates coincide.
And finally, the form of
the estimates that we get is
a linear function in the xi's.
And this linearity is a very
convenient property to have,
because it allows
further analysis
of these ways of
obtaining estimates.
How do we interpret
this formula?
What we have here
is the following.
Each one of the
xi's gets multiplied
by a certain coefficient,
which is 1 over the variance.
And in the denominator,
we have the sum
of all of those coefficients.
So what we really have here is
a weighted average of the xi's.
Now keep in mind that
those xi's are not
all of them of the same kind.
One term is x0, which
is the prior mean,
whereas the remaining xi's are
the values of the observations.
So there's something
interesting happening here.
We combine the values
of the observations
with the value of
the prior mean.
And in some sense,
the prior mean
is treated as just one
more piece of information
available to us.
And it is treated in
a sort of equal way
as the other observations.
The weight that we have
in this weighted average
are that each xi gets divided
by the corresponding variance.
Does this make sense?
Well, suppose that sigma
i squared is large.
This means that the noise
term Wi is very large.
So Xi is very noisy.
And so it's not a useful
observation to have.
And in that case, it
gets a small weight.
So the weights are
determined by the variances
in a way that is quite sensible.
Those observations that
will get the most weight
will be those observations for
which the corresponding noise
variance is small.
So the solution to this
estimation problem that we just
went through has
many nice properties.
First, we stay within the world
of normal random variables,
because even the
posterior is normal.
We stay within the world
of linear functions
of normal random
variables, and the form
of the formula that
we have, itself,
has an appealing
intuitive content.